credo di avere un tantino esagerato
stavolta cornuti della tutti ragazzi e
benvenuti a questo nuovo video sono pari
j
e oggi siamo su api arriveremo prima o
poi l'episodio cento in questa vita non
si sa mai troppo team b partiamo per i
soli visto che ciò la mano a posto
aspetta aspetta uomo che il cazzo di
spada era finta aspettate un attimo
questa cosa veramente triste oma 16 gen
ma è la sua ragazza e la spada della
chicco è finta ho capito la cia la mano
monca però nicchia ma sei serio tacito o
a michele uccisi entrambi ma chissene
famiglia mini wheels
ma cos'è come ho fatto a faccia con e
bellissima a stronzi stronzi lemme
togliti madonna quanto quando c'è ma
cos'era miglia come arrotolato ragazzi
non posso perdere controllo uno shock è
una cosa che non esiste nella vita
perfetto fetovaia uk e monte fato bene
ok ho appena scassato il cervello di uk
l'annuncio al cervello che mi sono
dimenticato rock swing christmas reale
sa è bellissimo quando si arriva natale
il periodo natalizio è bello perché
iniziano i livelli natalizi sola questo
si capisce
welcome to rock swing casi oh che bello
mi dice anche che regali di natale
ricevo oppure mipi per il culo è la cosa
che ancora non ho capito gli stili velli
rock swing
ma qual è il fine cioè non io io
continuo a fare lo swing da 82 episodi
senza un perché la mia gamba ragazzi
voglio una gamba nuova per natale anzi
da questa doniamo regalo
ringraziamo iddio che c'era il muro
invisibile perché sono facciamo una
figura di merda pid run uno speed run su
april se l'uovo questo tipo rock swing
se cose si chiama cristo non gratis
anche tu lo zio le scale e le devi
saltare non so se hai capito
bravo ma vaffan pravo
porca [ __ ] sono volto falconara non mi
prendo un braccio in consolazione c'è
proprio
sono morto quindi sono incazzato oddio
r2 d2
ma come vabbè fermi fermi fermi date
degli oscar a questo livello
vi prego secondo me non lo faceva così
bene manco jj abrams che è la madonna se
starò la mamma voglio questo per natale
voglio questa cosa come si comprano
vendono su amazon come si chiama break
dance machine
no no non è questa non è la stessa cosa
mi stai mentendo cala [ __ ] [ __ ]
wickets ed è vero sarà in scala uno a
uno alto 12.000 metri non è meglio una
bella portano in sé ma perché stiamo
andando a marzo ma [ __ ]
scusate io non stavo guardando come nel
cascato il traguardo in testa va bene
c'è modi alternativi di finire i livelli
ragazza falco un doge e questo mi
mancava c'era secolo non faccia da punto
e ci sarà un motivo erano faccia sapere
la dr mi arrivano spiega melo è
impossibile come posso sapere da dove mi
arrivano gli arpioni spiegano lo zio
devo andare sì va beh
vado a culo solo esclusivamente a culo
ma anzi non posso più andare a culo
perché vi culo non ce l'ho più
ok sono vivo non è vero non sono io
certo che sì magari uno spiedino
perfetto laga credo che sia in assoluto
il livello più incasinato della storia
senza
dubbio c'è un vero che [ __ ] non c'è
più i piedi non c'è più i piedi non c'è
più bene noi ragazzi nel possibile non
si può fare su livelli e assurdo cioè
ris far questo risparmiate melo
[ __ ] mi son rotto e stato bello
regalatemi la pazienza per finirlo a
natale 3021 donkey vice
siamo nel 3021 la madonna che macchina è
devo c'è quella macchina lì e io vado
così bene una palla alla demolizione che
non uccide e fa finta di uccidere
fantastico ma siamo nell'anno 3021 vi
spiegate perché nell'anno 3021 e tutto
metallico cos'è il metallo ha preso
possesso del dell'universo di arpioni
iarc anno sono appiani laser per certo
che saranno pieni normali non andavano
bene ok gli arpioni laser ragazzi si
utilizzeranno nel 2021
non c'è le mani cioè si cela le mani ma
non le posso usare vuoi dirmi che nel
3021 non avete inventato porte che si
aprono normalmente 107 sede stranzi o
cosa c'è per caso un dottore futuristico
che mi sono appena tranciato che la mia
stessa no niente sono rimasto così
minchia che posta sul pene zio stai bene
eh no non sto bene per niente si tira
una botta alle falle cosa sono diventato
ma cos'è e la roba è diventato threshold
3021 comunque proprio un anno di merda
cioè non xbox wangi la way se voglio
vincere xbox
voglio vincere e l'xbox c'è scritto cosa
devo fare per votare 5 stelle per
vincere xbox e votiamo 5 stelle
provinciali ci consultiamo 5 stelle xbox
in movimento se se quelle battute più
brutte dell'anno facciamo una
compilation e metteteci pure questa
perché porca [ __ ] fa veramente schifo l
era il ragazzo centrale perché mi
mancava essere trovati la scritta dice
qui ovviamente un troll ever quindi
costa minchia non posso fare così perché
c'è
no
ah sì ma sei scemo chi quan to pass
through ovviamente clicchiamo rosso no
chiamo il verde perché rosso loro si
aspettano che io kick in rosso per
sbagliare
e invece io clicker o il verde esatto
psicologia inversa ho vinto mammamia
manco freud ok questa non è la vittoria
lo sapevo
capisco messo la vita camorra ed io lo
sapevo inutile che jam più cosa che sono
su una bici quest'anno nella vita vera
non arriveremo mai la vittoria ragazzi
ok come non detto morte cattiva ma covo
cattiva force lo stronzo walk on through
evil dead deve morire il fratello di
indigestione di amen ems cam ignota
ladra va culo culo di così perfetto
salvai decima set enel che noi ed è
certo visto papa che bravo visto ragazzi
non guardate andate a vedere un bel film
ad e retro machete vader oddio sono in
rosso vivo arrivo sa vivo non ci credo
sopravvissuto o un pene mobile ragazzi
non ha questa roba hanno un basso
youtube non posso metterla venire
lasciamo perdere quel forum screen sono
quasi io c'ho la mano monca aspetto
quanto vuoi
così nola vero puoi scrivere sulla
tastiera j
non è favi gente è impiccato ma che ne
so io
c'è tutto non azzeccata una lettera
comunque a gare a soggiorno che merda
la ragazza mi hanno capito che faccio
pagare a l'impiccato quindi tra perso la
prima volta mmq y r t mi chiama un po
più sconnessi tutte consonanti sono un
cena vocale o o ma non ce l'hai non c'è
da è a monsters mostri che ha ragazzo
lento sorrento nel corso lento e ramones
perché c'è una bambina che dondola
affanculo fare
ci proviamo questo devo fare trascinarmi
ma mancava la pena sta in piedi
bravo zio cosa ho schivato questa roba
non ho capito cosa ho giocato ragazzi
fotte 6 che testi io l'ho testa la tua
fortuna ora come sono fortunato a chi a
prendere il pallone in partenza alla
merda mamma ora che culo è re culo
qualcuno ha corrotto con 80 euro questo
gioco per farmi vincere a trito le cose
mica cotto e frullato aveva bene ad oggi
al ragazzo la lis pavic è chiamato anche
benedetta fa vicenza era il frullato
giusto per voi che è tanto il fisico di
maurizio merluzzo tv and bone boxes che
fa sempre bene in un frullato con
vitamina tv eccola la fa questa è
l'unica cosa non sana di tutto sto
casino poi chiudiamo chiudiamo e start
perfetto ragazzi è la scena e subito
dopo ragazzuoli vediamo di fare un po i
livelli miei perché ancora non non ho
trovato qualcosa che abbia veramente un
senso fa vj e le patate questo
sicuramente un senso ce l'ha come faccia
vince sta roba non da quel poco per
forza
ma dai su ancora vivo sono cose spingi
spingi come tua madre spinge senti
no non ti sei bravo bravo era difficile
insomma il raro bra o anche la gamba ti
sei portato il massimo della vita
lo dice in un per cento impossibile
facciamo questo e poi finiamo qui già
queste parte se ce la fai ti mando un
obama con le sue medaglie a casa tua
ce lo farà con le medaglie impacchettato
anche lui impacchettiamo il presidente
ragazzi non andare qui no non vado lì
tranquillo devo vincere così e non ad
esse va dopo a vincono muoio si ok va
bene perché non da ragazzi con quello
che l'episodio di oggi con altri livelli
che hanno dato un senso maggiore alla
mia vita e vi ringrazio
spero che vi sia piaciuto spero che ai
fini su un giorno acquisisca un senso
che sia ricordato sui libri di storia
spero che vi sia piaciuto al 100 ragazzi
servito è piaciuto al documento è un mi
piace anche a pagina di facebook e con
il video transizione senza vestiti
scritti ci vediamo così bello ragazzi